[Music]
here i have an advice
column and i will read to you guys the
question and
you guys could give me your thoughts
okay so it says
a question my work my partner's work
habits are atrocious
and then the question says my partner
beau has always had trouble keeping a
job for more than eight months
he told me it was mostly due to reasons
outside of his control like terrible
bosses is it his gay
that's boyfriend a specific question i'm
trying to imagine
what this is i feel like it's a girl
with a that's dating a that just moved
in with the dude and like oh [ __ ] this
dude isn't who
i thought he was a loser because they're
lovers right uh yes
okay they're lovers that's all i need to
know gender neutral lovers
okay so then i'll continue he says i've
generally supported him in his
employment search for the past few years
i have a pretty high powered career
myself
but i've always tried to keep that
separate and
not rub it in when he's had so much
trouble finding a good fit
working from home has starkly
illustrated what makes
beau such a bad employee i feel bad for
saying this but
it's hard to watch beau has few if any
organizational systems he writes down
tasks on random slips of paper which
then get lost that's organized and i
frequently hear him having to apologize
to folks for forgetting deadlines or
deliverables sounds like me
in meetings he rambles incessantly
yeah oh it does sound like chubby lives
in meetings he rambles incessantly
taking forever to get to his main
request if i was in a meeting with him
i'd just
tune out and avoid future meetings with
him when he's
when he's overwhelmed or stressed he
adopts a tone with people and makes them
feel bad for asking him to do things
that are 100 percent
part of his job i've coached many
entry-level employees over the years and
i know these behaviors are
definitely coachable it's not an
undeniable part of his personality
though i obviously wouldn't coach him
myself i
i'm thinking of recommending that he
reach out to a career counselor or
coach to help him with executive
functioning
he'd be so much more effective in his
job and i know he'd be happier
knowing he was doing a better job it's
hard to watch a bow
i almost said joke it's hard to watch bo
make these flip i can't unsee
joe now as you're describing this person
i can't even see it by justin
it's hard to watch bo make make these
fixable mistakes
over and over all the while
thinking there's nothing he can do to
change a situation
at the same time i know i'd get annoyed
if my partner tried to give me career
advice
beau is really sensitive about this
topic in particular what should i do i
feel like this person is really loving
yeah cause she didn't just drop the dude
because it wasn't like oh this is a
there's a turn off i'm [ __ ] bouncing
off this [ __ ] i thought it was a
gay couple was it gay couple it hasn't
been confirmed i don't know but only
because she's or he or she is really
trying to
help develop them find outside help make
this person better and
what this person is doing at their
occupation isn't
coming back and ruining the relationship
that they have or it's not affecting the
way
that he or she sees him and i'm like
that's that's pretty mature actually do
they work together
they're specifically explaining their
that they've now seen the work ethic
because we're in this pandemic and they
have to work from home together
i want to hear bo's side of the story i
bet you it's like
snow is so [ __ ]
ocd so controlling
snow has to have everything like one way
or like snow's freaking out
[ __ ] snow what does that have to do
with the way he and then the fact that
he can't even hold a job for
more than anything talking about cocaine
or oh
it's bow and snow yeah yeah yeah okay
okay thank you thank you thank you for
catching on thank you very much
does it affect their lives uh does beau
affect it to the point where
he's not making rent i don't know i feel
like i would
like instead of being like you need to
do these things i would try to adopt
these new ways of like
being better but say it's for me i'd be
like oh look
having a planner is so nice i can
schedule things now i'm so on time
it's kind of just hint my way there
they're like i like my random posters
i imagine they're like oh cool that
works for you these poses work great for
me
how did this person never see that
recklessness because i feel like
certain traits can be seen a mile away
well if this person's not punctual in
regular life
like how how could you not catch that
like certain traits will bleed if he's
always late to your dates or other
things
who do you expect to catch them beau
himself no no no
partner no why are they surprised is
what i'm wondering well i think you also
have high social iq
i think a lot of people they they don't
they can't see that like i can tell how
this person treats their library card
and i can kind of extrapolate how that
would you know but i think
a lot of people they just kind of just
see things of how they are
you know like i could play basketball
with someone and i could feel their
energy see how they problem solve on the
court i go
i can kind of see how this person will
run a business actually i know what
i don't think a lot of people true but i
think i think for this case too it's
kind of like maybe
all the things that are wrong with beau
in the workplace and what holds them
back in the workplace might come off as
charming
and actually propel them in a social
situation there's that too so it's like
he's spontaneous he loves talking so
much and he's like really fun to be
around all the time you know but then
when it needs to be systematic and for
work and serious
that playfulness is that his own
hindrance but obviously it didn't propel
him in the workplace yeah it didn't yeah
but socially he could have like
nailed the uh interview because he's so
fun
and then he got the job and then they're
like irresponsible
and then like he loses the job which is
why i think snow
over here uh is like barcelona taking a
really mature approach to try and be
like
i understand that me trying to coach you
in this space is not necessarily going
to be helpful for our relationship and
the way that i want to perceive
the relationship we have but uh
obviously
hearing it from another professional or
credible source to like help get
his career on track like that's yeah
like he said like that's [ __ ]
compassionate no should have came home
be like you know why you're a loser
you don't [ __ ] got your life together
you keep living like this
and i stay limp can't [ __ ] you anymore
that plus a little tact would be right
around there but that's gonna
that's gonna hurt the relationship well
how would you handle this than if you
were snow i mean why do you think i'm
single
or okay anyone else in this room i'd be
i'd be single too you'd be single yeah
so i think like
so for me i think like that's why i i
really admire uh
snow in this situation because they are
very mature
but for me i think because uh
i'm attracted to high performers
if someone's not high performing it
already becomes a turn off
so it's like i i'm like oh what like
everyone at work hates your ass you're a
[ __ ] scumbag you can't
turn in reports and [ __ ] on time i'm
like but at this point
like i guess like considering the
situation that we know like
the facts is like okay they're in a
relationship to the point where now they
live
in the same place and they're working in
the same home so
it's like some sort of like they are um
yeah i don't know how committed they are
either yeah that's what the word
there's some sort of but if they just
lived for under a year i would move out
i think it just depends too because
it doesn't sound like it's damaging
their relationship
it's more like damaging the image and
respect
one person has so it's not like their
behavior is so bad that it's like
starting to cause
so much stress on snow where like you're
not [ __ ] paying the bills on time
you're not doing oh my god it's more
like
it's more like looking at him like i
know you can do better
yeah potential you have potential and
you're i'm losing respect and you're
shattering this image of who i have of
you yeah because the title of this
article
is or like the story or whatever is
called help
quarantine quarantining with my partner
has made me realize he's terrible at his
job so i really do think it's like an
image based thing yeah and then isn't
that her or
snow's issue yeah that's obviously it'd
be my it would be my issue because
because that image is shattered then i'm
not as attracted
so i would have for me i would move
because my image is shattered so your
solution to that is to just move away
and not deal with that
because i'm not as mature as snow where
they can like i'm gonna especially if
they're that so the commitment matters a
lot if they've only been living here for
like a year
then it's easier to just find someone
else let's say it wasn't a year
i don't think i don't think leaving that
situation necessary lack of maturity
i think it's just maybe you just
understand what you want you have a
different priority
maybe but i think you would at least
talk or try
wait i'm not just going to pack my
bathroom already
[Laughter]
well do you guys want to hear the answer
that the advice columnist gave him
was it like yeah if bo
sucks good ass dick keep that boo
what if snow is a girl if bo
eats [ __ ] really good then it's worth
it
keep he could have a golden penis that
is a variable that nobody would write in
an article and i'm not trying to go into
the image
i'm just saying he could have a [ __ ]
golden penis and sometimes that
that is a very powerful i'm not just
saying penis a perfect
golden vagina maybe is an analogy for
somebody else but
point is i like penises point is uh
he could have a golden penis and that
could be the
charisma that we're talking about in the
social life and the latter
whereas an actual strategic
organizational points it's like you're
terrible at your job
very true your penis is glory for some
reason he can't hold down a job
but he can dick down his wife so it's
like
partner partner yeah partner partner he
or she he or she
partner partner in crime so the answer
says your best
long-term solution is probably going to
involve finding ways
not to watch bo at work obviously that's
ignore that part giving given that
you're both working from home but
look for as much space space as possible
to put between your workplace and his
make sure your office setups face
different directions all that stuff that
way it won't feel
quite so crucial to get him to take your
advice right away uh i want you to be
able to find some peace and quiet for
yourself whether he's receptive to a
conversation or not
um oh because it they also said like you
know you should just approach him and be
like hey you know do you want this
advice
so then they continue when it comes to
approaching a topic your partner
sensitive about i tend to think
it's best to be direct and ask straight
out rather than try to hit your way
through the conversation or ask a lot of
leading questions and this quote we've
talked about
we've talked before about your trouble
keeping jobs for more than a year
and i have a suggestion i think might be
helpful do you want to hear about it or
would you rather not
so that's the example if he's interested
great you can identify a few major
issues because focusing
on what's more most important or easiest
to fix rather than giving him a highly
detailed explanation of
everything he's doing might be better
right i'm doing wrong might be better
and suggest a few coaches if he's not
you can back off
and let him keep learning from his own
mistakes either way look for ways to
scale back and disengage from his work
habits after you have this conversation
so you don't find yourself trying to
monitor him for progress
all the time you guys know i've never
been fired before that's surprising
is it yeah but then again
you've always been in this position for
as long as i've known you so i
have no idea how you would never see
someone else's assistant yeah
how many times have you been unemployed
how many jobs that i've had oh my
goodness
i don't even i've been working since
like 15 16. we're not talking about like
being like a hooker or anything no no
like legal jobs like working at
yeah i worked at target i worked at a
call center
i worked at a shipping company i worked
at a water company
i worked at a restaurant i worked at
what the [ __ ] else did i do that was the
main things that i remember
i worked at a market
yeah i never been fired and i kept jobs
over a couple years too that's cool
yeah what did you think about the answer
pouring
at the end of the day it okay like i
said like
it's just his work style he just might
be annoying because it you wouldn't do
it that way
but then if he's paying the bills and
he's doing things
why does it matter right like her
answer's like
he writes things on napkins and forgets
it's to me that sounds like a control
issue
it doesn't sound like an issue of if it
was like
what about the issue that he is he has
expressed that he just can't even keep a
job for more than a year
and like that's clearly a problem that
is a problem it's pretty funny and then
like as a partner
yeah like and then you see like this is
clearly like fixable things that i am
actually experiencing but i don't want
to step in and like cause harm to our
relationship
but then like do you think as the person
that would be able to help like
they should just keep their mouth shut
and be like okay keep struggling i think
she's bunching up things that she that
sounds more like personal problems
versus
for him to help to help him so like if
it was about
uh keeping a job specifically
then it's about um i also think that
maybe he's not fulfilled too
like he has to find where this job will
work for him the work style that works
for his style you know what i mean
yeah because we all know some high-level
professional ass people and they're
skilled
but they're absent-minded and but
they're high performers
so these the things that she were she
was calling out it
sounds to me just more like a personal
issue
it wasn't just the the fact that he has
no organizational systems it's also the
fact that
he has attitude when people are telling
him to do something that are part of his
job like there's like
clear like i think it's like a
compatibility issue
because it seems like this girl really
uh prioritizes
professionalism so i think that is
almost more so like how
someone does something that's more
important than what they do yes and
maybe for him i think what joe's saying
is maybe he just hasn't found
what he really wants to do yet where the
professionalism can
flourish but then i think for her she's
probably viewing it from because it kind
of reminds me like how my mom is like
regardless of what you do if you do 10
different jobs you should do all 10 of
them well that's also assuming that he's
jumping from industry to industry
because we don't know that
all this time he's been doing the exact
same thing he's really passionate about
he's just sucks at keeping a job so then
this person the partner is seeing like
there's clearly a way to help i just
don't want to
like harm our relationship by getting
involved so then that's why they're
asking like
how should i go about it it also sounds
like if it is a girl she doesn't want to
turn into this person's mom
right like i don't want a mama or
babysitter or you know i think the
advice is really good whether or not
you're in a relationship with them
because
a lot of times people have different
learning styles too like i've taught
people
whether it's like a hobby or games or
whatever like teach people even how like
snowboard it's like
sometimes i'll ask them first i'm like
would you rather me
constantly tell you like what's wrong
what's wrong what's wrong for you fix it
like
right away or do you want me to be more
hands-off and then you can like learn as
you go and i'll
give you the big points later you know i
feel like it's the same thing with that
it's like
if you like can he handle the constant
criticism or not
but i think having that conversation
ahead of time and being like hey
i want to help you is it okay if i you
know give you some pointers or
should i just leave you alone reading
that answer really helped me personally
a lot because i
tend to be like i've said this before
i'm i'm a controlling person and it
comes from trauma
but like so hearing this it made me
actually view the way i approach you
casey a lot of the times my bow to you
or am i snow gumbo no i'm saying i'm
or i guess and you're both you're
definitely which one of you is joe
don't write all post-it notes anymore
the point is
the notes in your phone account as
opposed to they don't blow away only if
you lose your phone
what do you think the point is that the
approach i really appreciated
the advice because then i i instead of
like trying to
jam my ideas or my ways down your throat
i can approach you and say like
are you even like do you even want to
hear this like because i
i see a situation or you seem to be
struggling and
i think it would be easier this way but
i'm not going to tell you the way
if you don't want to hear it and i think
that was really helpful for me
personally being a controlling person
to be fair let's take a look at snow
here
if you're compelled to write an article
about your partner i think you're also
one step farther than the average
joe you know what i mean like being able
to
res like perceive and understand that
your partner in the workspace
uh maybe has some habits that they can
fix and you maybe have skills
you maybe have advice you may be even
seeking advice but i think if you have
either enough energy time of day or it's
pressuring you so much that you're
capable of writing and seeking like
public help for it it's not a bad thing
it's totally doable
but i also think that that is also very
like you understanding is a very very
deliberate and certain way
it would compel you to write about it
you know what i mean and share your
experience and seek
to see if there's like a most right way
to handle this unique situation i think
that already
is something unique and amazing about
snow
but just like very much so so that
person who's capable of writing an
article
who's also looking at somebody who like
writes on posts and throws away like
that must be very conflicting to the way
that you would normally do things and
understand that so i think it's a
compatibility thing it's like one
person's
extreme professionalism yeah like
grounded knows how to channel my
thoughts okay i need uh third-party
advice this is how i do things and
versus someone just seems it's just like
you know i'm just spontaneous just going
with the flow sounds going like you know
what i know how to fix this
i need human resources you know what i'm
saying it's like a
very like this is the way to go about it
it's like oh no i don't know how to
do this i need professional help that's
why you know what i'm saying
it's an issue it's a snow issue or it's
a she has an issue with the way he does
things
that's why the advice was great where
it's like create that space don't let it
like dwell let him learn on his own and
if you can't be with them leave yeah if
someone doesn't want to learn
something they're not going to learn it
if you should be doing this so it's kind
of
why do you control their destiny like
you can't do anything about it true but
do they suck dick good though
hello guys thank you guys so much for
watching all of our videos and i know
it's been a million years in the making
but we
finally got just kidding news merch
yup so make sure you go down to the
store below and you can run around
yeah you can get a piece of jk news and
thank you guys for supporting
thank you bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you